hey guys I'm Greg Alba and I am Brianna
white today we're gonna watch the
trailer for ty shared in his new movie
love detour ty Sheridan standout role in
Xmen apocalypse from my understanding
please it was the highlight of the film
he's the one everyone talked about he
played James Marsden me he played I
thought he played Quicksilver right no
it's definitely not know the guy from
American Horror Story played Cyclops
Evan Peters yes players he plays Cyclops
yeah he wasn't very good IMDb that
wasn't very good I thought you should
have would have been a better
Quicksilver yeah this is interesting you
yeah well it's funny in some ways
depending on your ability to not like
witness it's a good good explanation oh
my like any shot of the trunk to to have
an area expertise you need something
dude that's Stephen Moyer I think it'd
be something if someone were to teach
him a lesson
if you could cut yourself in half and
it's over the two sides they don't even
know what the other one is done you live
your life clean hands would you do it
yes made the right choice you had to
come you'd be sitting at home right now
think about what could have been is that
what is kill this damn killing tight mr.
killing time yeah like should I regret
the things you do just the things you
don't
love that sweater Jason Bourne
[Music]
I got you all wrong didn't I I got me
just right wait for me
cool interesting i wonder if the fellas
gonna have like a linear type of
storytelling I wonder if is it feels
like it's gonna be a little scatter shot
yeah are we gonna is this a little
representation like are we gonna get
split screens through parts of the movie
yeah I like the choice of the split
screen that they were using showing dual
thoughts showing like contrasting to
version yeah yeah I thought that was
about the other unions doing and Tye
Sheridan looks like he's doing a really
good job yeah I enjoy roles when when
actors are doing like the on edge
paranoia kind of vibe yeah you're right
I got something new reminds you of like
I don't know like Ray Liotta and
Goodfellas or DiCaprio in a lot of
movies I don't know how quite to
describe this but like body [ __ ] does a
similar thing for me where you like
watch a person slowly get more and more
something over the ass of a movie and
this it looks like more and more you
know sort of wild and primal and harsh
but I wouldn't be surprised at the last
half hour of this film leyland in Mexico
at the titty twister and then a bunch of
vampires right I love to start then
trend of just like every bit of lace
from distance of it just dusk rolling
people's is like breaking act 3 and all
of a sudden they're vampires no reason
just make that like a Hollywood mean cuz
i feel like this film will probably get
crazier than what the trailers letting
all the reason why i'm wondering
scattershot is BK or if it's gonna be
Linear's because they kept doing a lot
of cutting back to what we saw early in
the trailer cutting back to later
moments coming back and forth back were
like a lot of cutting back to stephen
moyer i am vampires i can't i still
havent decoupled him from bill it's
impossible yet especially cuz he's
playing vampires and other stuff too so
like stephen moyer scene they kept
cutting back and forth to like very
similar moments oh yeah hey I felt like
they showed us some of the same moments
like several times and I'm wondering
like it's directing and editing style of
this I feel like it's going to be a
strong representation of what the vibe
of this movie is really all about
because yeah it kind of seems like this
ty Sheridan character has a lot of
thoughts constantly racing we're seeing
out this think about that
I feel like the kind of scanner shop
cutting back and forth is representing
like the kind of trauma that he's going
through I hope the movie feels like you
know ever every now and again though
gussied up a trailer but but at least
what I'm getting from what we're shown
here like it looks like it could
probably be both nonlinear and maybe
they'll use that split screen is some
kind of transition or I think we check
in like a way to go from one plot to the
other simultaneously exactly cuz I'm
wondered about that before like what
would have like what if I could you know
be two people it also looks like the
execution is very uh very assured yeah
yeah this has a strong visual and a
strong sonic style yeah the visual
senses gray the actors look great my
concern is how come how's the story in a
play out I liked my one concern these
weird mind your mind bender movies where
everyone's a little detached yeah like
for some reason that thing works for you
but yeah that's what I always worried
about what these is is it going to pay
off its high-concept yeah because
sometimes things fall apart when it
comes time to tie it all together so I'm
really curious as to how they tie this
all together and what it's truly about
cuz it's the other thing that's cool is
like I'm getting a sense for what's
happening but not really like one text
of what's going I feel like he like
killed his dad to like get some money or
some [ __ ] long lost it into while
grieving for his dying mother struggles
to decide whether he should kill is
unfaithful stepfather that's what i mean
by cutting back and forth it looks like
it's a lot of it is probably not even
really happening it kind of looks like
it might just be in his mind likee of
him thinking should i do this should I
not what if you have yourself to new
there's that too that's what he said
like how sci-fi his OSIS categorizes a
thriller cuz that looks kind of like
like how literal is that in context in
the trailer do you ever get a sense like
is it just like a trip is like a fantasy
I'm not sure because what I liked about
the the way the trailer was portraying
the way this film's gonna be done is it
kind of feels like I like let these
characters aren't crazy drugs but
they're not yeah it's just they're
dealing with intense life-or-death
situations he's like tempted to become
something more like evil in a way so
that naturally causes your mind to sort
of go a little insane I like seeing that
kind of scatter shot by but like wow
these guys not showing it like doing
drugs this whole trailer maybe they do
it in the movie I like that vibe I like
they're all
coker samina see how happy this is what
I'm curious and a little confused about
because I don't see how half of the
images from the trailer relate to the
story with his dad at all again it's how
literal is the twist there is like is it
really is it some kind of weird
cross-dimensional thing words like you
have two versions playing out at the
same time yeah I don't know maybe that
was made clear and I just missed it but
I couldn't tell like how sci-fi or not
this was or maybe was reading too much
into it and I just plays out from A to Z
but it makes me wonder then you see all
those X that that extra [ __ ] were there
like out in the desert and stuff you're
like wow this looks like it's gonna go a
lot of plans oh he gets weird and so
like I don't know how it fits with the
love letters well what I'm thinking is
his mom died it was his biological mom
and then the stepfather inherited the
money okay so like Nina the life
insurance money and then he kills his
step dad to like obtain the money that's
why I'm guessing maybe not made clear
the trailer but that's what I'm guessing
yeah yeah I don't know it's like I guess
that's that's a better thing than not
like this looks really cool and I'm a
little confused so this time makes sense
of why he he would kill a stepfather
that's what I'm trying to make sense it
like oh yeah other than the fact he was
unfaithful neighbor her mom kick the
truck does make you wonder look like one
that's a good trailer to make you go
like I don't know much about this film
but i am going like what is really going
on and I kind of want to find out yeah
well it seems like i don't know the best
i could glean from it is that in some
way or another and with the logline in
mind he's figuring out whether like what
happens if i kill him or what happens if
I don't alright rejects if you're new to
the channel subscribe today we'd get
accepted run the outra get except a guy
now truly accept you John is real cool
sorry to Jory facebook.com slash blue
mouse and facebook.com slash through yet